اعداد الاصابات وهي بالالاف اضافه الى
اعداد يعني القتلى الذي هو في تزايد مستمر
يفوق امكانيات اطراف الصراع في في سوريا
سواء كان النظام او حتى
المعارضه ربما اوضاع النظام افضل بقليل من
اوضاع المعارضه التي يعني تعيش حاله حصار
من جهه الداخل
السوري وايضا يعني يعني قله الموارد وايضا
قله الامكانيات والمعابر المغلقه تضع يعني
المعارضه امام كارثه انسانيه للتعامل مع
هذا الملف الانساني الذي يصبح اكثر تعقيدا
بمرور
الدقائق وليس فقط يعني
[موسيقى]
الساعات يعني اعداد القتلى يرتفع بالمئات
وليس بالعشرات مثلا منذ حوالي ساعتين كان
اعداد القتلى في مناطق المعارضه 221 الان
اصبح نحن نتحدث عن 179 قتيل زياده على
العدد الاساسي في غضون ساعتين فقط نتحدث
عن الاف الاصابات عشرات العائلات عالقه
تحت الانقراض لا تستطيع فرق الدفاع المدني
والفرق الشعبيه التي تشكلت لدعم يعني فريق
الدفاع المدني الانتشار الجثث ورفع
الانقراض والركاب
المنازل بينما في مناطق في مناطق نظام
ايضا يعني كان العدد
337 اصبح 404 نحن نتحدث عن اكثر من تنميات
قتيل في حصيله في حصيله غير نهائيه في
عموم سوريا ونتحدث عن الاف
المصابين اصابات مختلفه من صغيره الى
متوسطه الى اصابات كبيره ودقيقه تتطلب
تدخل جراحي يعني لا الامكانيات الطبيه ولا
الكادر الطبيه ولا حتى الوقت يسعف يعني
القطاع الطبي للتعامل مع الاعداد الكبيره
المصابين الكثير منهم اصاباتهم عصبيه
نتيجه يعني كسور في العظام ويعني التضرر
في الجمجمه وتضرر في الدماغ وبالتالي يعني
تحتاج مناطق المعارضه وايضا حتى مناطق
النظام الى التدخل خارجي اسعافي
لتحقيق امكانيه السيطره على هذه
المشكله او الكارثه الكبيره الحاصله في
سوريا